thank you tom
well uh good evening uh fellow
councillors and uh special welcome to
members of the public are watching on
youtube
uh welcome to the annual general meeting
of torres district council on monday
26th of april 2021
start with apologies and register of
attendees please thank you chair i have
apologies
from councillor heppel councillor
pennington
councillor ford councillor wiseman
and councillor cottle hunkin
thank you and
i will now go through lists of
counselors
present counselor bowton here
counselor a present
counselor bright president
can't slip around present chancellor
bushby
president councillor christie
present answer clark president
councillor craigie yeah
pennsylvant
not present sandra thank you tom
councillor gab president
councillor hackett presents
councillor haines president
councillor harding yeah
chancellor hawkins
no he's not present oh he's just joining
now sandra
okay
okay counselor hicks
present cancer hudson
jones hi
councillor langford president
councillor laws present pencil a leather
yeah pencil and lock present
chancellor mcgarth
present counselor mackenzie
president councillor manly
president pencil newton present
pencil rossi president
councillor watson president
sandra councillor dart has now joined
the meeting
and can i just check we've got a hand
raise is that councillor hepple
it is it is me uh yeah i'm i'm
joining hopefully just for the first
hour um i'm really struggling so
um i'm i'm hopefully here for the first
hour
thank you councillor thank you
brenton hello hi um i see
as the outgoing chair i need now to take
the nominations
yes i'll just put a couple of sentences
before you do that
steve thank you okay thanks thank you
yeah well before i hand over to the
chief executive
steve hurst i would like to as i'm not
standing
as chair again i would like to make a
couple of thank yous please
uh because it has been a very difficult
couple of years
as you were well aware actually i mean
i've been chairing meetings for over 40
years and this has been one of the most
challenging i have to say
but um i would first of all like to
thank all the staff
who have been uh helping me along the
way especially those involved with the
technology
they've been brilliant you know if they
can teach me things then they they
really are
they're in the wrong job really should
be teaching really but however they know
very good indeed
and of course um uh you counselors who
have uh
tolerated my um uh methodology if you
might put it that way
but uh it's been very civilized and i'm
very pleased with the way things have
gone actually
but in particular i'd like to thank
councillor christie who's uh
when i've been especially last year when
i was very ill
for a period of time he uh stepped in
very quickly ably and um did a great job
and
i would particularly like to thank him
for the for the work he did
so with no more do i hand over to uh
steve to
conduct the next item thank you
thanks thanks councillor brenton um just
just for
members of the public's benefit so what
we're doing uh this evening is torridge
district council's annual meeting
where we elect or where the council
elects members to a variety of posts
uh things like the chair of council vice
chair leader deputy leader
and chair and vice chairs of the many
committees
um i'll only start the meeting and i'll
hand over to the
uh chair once uh they're elected
so without further ado i seek
nominations for the
chair of council tom could you let me
know who's put their hands up first so i
can take them
in the correct order yeah steve the
first hand raise is councilman goff
uh councillor mcgoff thank you much mr
chief executive um
my proposal for sheriff council would be
councillor
doug bushby
thank you and is there a second er for
councillor bushby
i'll second that i've got my name on
hand up
my hands up um are there any other
nominations uh councillor hodgson's got
her hands raised
steve angela hodgson no it was just to
second councillor bushby
okay um there aren't any other
hands up that's cool we've got a
proposal and a seconder
so sandra could you take the votes
please
yes thank you uh
council about him for
councillor brenton or councillor bright
or chancellor brown or
councillor bushby well i'd better say
four haven't i
councillor christy oh councillor
or councillor craigie
or councillor dart
or councillor ford
sorry tom did i see councillor ford
during the meeting
yes he has sandra
councillor ford i've just unmuted you
counselor ford
thanks ever so much mate i appreciate
that because most people like to move me
all the time mate happy days again
thank you gab or
chancellor hackett or
councillor haynes or pencil harding
or cancer hawkins
against i can definitely do
pencil hair pull four
or penciller hutchins for
councillor inch for councillor james
ball councillor jones
four councillor langford for
counselling laws or counseling leather
poor counselor lock or
counselor mcgoff or counselor mackenzie
four councillor manly
or councillor newton four
uh councillor rossi four
chancellor watson or
that's just two against chair
um thank you so uh what normally happens
at this stage
is uh the chair of council is elected
um and they ordinarily declare their
acceptance
of office and sign the declaration in in
the book obviously we can't do that in a
virtual meeting
but councillor bushby um if you could
read the acceptance
of office and then we'll arrange uh
tomorrow for
the signing of the book and i'll see the
handover from the
past year thank you steve i have done
and i'll come in the office and do that
thank you
having been elected to the office of
chair of the council of authorities for
council declare
that i take that office upon myself and
we duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability this declaration was made and
signed before me
uh proper office of the council that's
steve hurst
uh elected chair to attend and sign the
declaration at riverbank house which i
will do
tomorrow if it's appropriate thank you
thank you chair so i'll hand over to you
to continue the meeting
thank you
do i need to be cool horse or anything
tom was that done i've
made you co-host chair so if you open
your participants then as people raise
their hands you'll see them
come on the right list thank you well
before we actually move
on to the next uh agenda item i'd like
to take this opportunity to thank cancer
brenton for the
sterling work that he's done um over the
last couple of years as
as chair of torres sister council he did
say it was
extraordinary times and you know i would
absolutely agree with him
so um if if this was a face-to-face
meeting in the council chambers i would
be leading a round of applause for you
uh counselor brenton but in the absence
of that will you please accept
um on behalf of all my fellow counselors
our sincere thank yous
thank you item three on the agenda
is to elect the vice share of council
and i would like to propose
um councillor christie and i have a
second referee
yeah pete watson are there any other
nominations
in the absence of any other nominations
then um do we need to take a vote on
this
or yes
okay sandra if you could run through
that please
yeah thank you chair uh council about
him
at four councillor brenton
all right um four pencil
bright four
councillor brown or councillor bushby
or councillor christy
oh councillor clark
or councillor craigie
or ansel dart
or councillor ford
boy counsellor gab
or counselor hackett for
councillor haynes or councillor harding
or cancer hawkins
for chancellor james four
councillor jones four chancellor
langford
four councillor laws or
cancer leather four penciller lock
four penciller mcgarth
or maxine mckenzie
four pencil manly
four chancellor newton four
pence la rossi or
and councillor watson or sandra sorry
we've always got councillor heppell
oh sorry councillor have po apologies
poor thank you that's unanimous chair
thank you very much sandra and i look
forward to working with councillor
christie
um indeed the same way that councillor
brenton did with uh all his wealth and
experience i'm sure it'll be
very useful to me in the coming year uh
item four on the agenda public
contributions
sorry if i could if uh the vice chair
councillor christie could also read the
the declaration of acceptance of office
jumping mcgonabe councillor christie
over here all right thank you
can i just say thank you for uh that
unanimous vote
uh it's very kind of you um i peter
christie have been elected to the office
of vice chair of the council of torridge
declared that i take that office upon
myself and will
duly and faithfully fulfill the duties
of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability
thank you and again again we'll arrange
with councillor christie to come in and
sign the register
um is that tomorrow i'm i have to point
out i'm still the mayor of biddeford i'm
still doing mayor oral things tomorrow
so i might have to do some other time
but
yeah whatever you call them anyway thank
you so uh item four public
contributions are i'll see if there's
none registered to speak
is that correct yeah that's correct yeah
okay
so move on then to item five uh to
consider correspondence or
any other business especially brought
forward by the chair well clearly i
don't have any
at the moment is it uh customary to
invite the chief executive to
ask if he's got any okay i haven't got
anything either
okay thank you uh item six
to answer questions submitted under
procedural rule not
a9 um there has been a letter from
um councillor ford that's been received
and i see it's been
answered by sean carney so i take it we
just received that
that letter and that response thank you
um i'm a letter follow-up
i beg your pardon i think you'll find
the cancer
yeah i think you're fine under
procedural rules i know you knew this
she'll be allowed to follow up
okay coaching forward if you think that
you need to follow up on that
um well it's definitely i do chair if
you just give me and i think the public
have a right to know from
the war member
i want no interruptions because i've had
too much of that last two or three
months so
sean carney has already admitted they
are not a club
right with other countries they have
stated they had several communications
with a council i've been talking to
really nice people
or i was saying brackets gullible
councillors
counselors have received communication
on headed paper stating the club
stickers have been issued for club
members
when did i the follow-up question will
be when did i
first ask for clarification of club
status
one man speaking for himself and not a
union
if gordon sparks would like to call me
direct
i will talk to him but no other tim pop
press so i want to answer and i've got
correspondence here i'm old enough
approved the council has had
correspondence
with mr gub or the pwc club and how much
do you want because the ford squad's
going to be in there in a minute thank
you
thank you cassidy ford uh item
seven you know move on to item seven
which is
i would like an answer please when did i
first
ask for clarification of the status of
the
jet ski club which don't exist back to
sean carney please
well i mean
public listening here they said public
debate transparency
this matter has been debated um at a
variety of
of committees and as far as i would i
missed by misrepresentation
chair because somebody's been claiming
and i normally law
right now just sean carney answer me a
simple question
when did councillor forward ask for
firstly for clarification
of status of club
well that may be the case country before
but as i said you know this
is the case this
has been debated by two committees and
have been drawn to a conclusion we've
drawn a line under that yes because
you've been led to believe by
false misrepresentation do you know
legal status i don't think you do
well i don't really know whether this is
at the end agm whether this is the time
or the place to
have an argument or a debate i'll i'll
debate
anytime you like me well
can i suggest then that you know this
matter is
don't worry the fourth squad's gonna be
in there shortly mate happy days thank
you carry on
okay item seven on the agenda is the
election
of the leader of the council can i have
any proposals please
chair i've got councillor mcgoffs hand
raised yep
cashler mcgolf very much mr chairman mr
chairman i like to oppose
councillor ken james the current leader
i think ken's done a great job over the
past two years it's been very
challenging
and as leader of the conservative team i
think that the general sense of our team
is we're very happy what ken's done
it's not been an easy time for him and
nice to see torres go forward in a
positive way
and i think ken is the person the
leaders through this thank you
uh second or please
it's councillor hackett speaking i would
like to second
councillor ken james okay thank you are
there any other nominations
chair got councillor newton's hand
raised coaster newton
i was purely put raised my hand earlier
to second that nomination
but uh councillor hackett obviously
wasn't waiting for such things
okay not to worry thank you thank you
very much okay let's
bend judy propose a second ed can you
take that to the vote sandra please
thank you chad councillor bounton
for taylor brenton
councillor four sorry
councillor bright or
or pencil dart
four councillor ford
councillor ford
sorry happy days for thank you
counselor gab um
four but can we ask everybody to move
please it's quite difficult listening
here this evening
thank you
[Music]
pencil hair kit for
council haims or cancer harding
pencil hawkins four
he's left the meeting sandra
thank you counselor hicks
poor chancellor hudson oh
cancer hurley or councillor hutchins
or councillor wrench or
councillor james for
councillor jones or
councillor langford or
cancer laws or that's a leather
poor cancer lock or
handsome mcgrath or cancer mckenzie
for hensler manly or
chancellor newton four councillor rossi
four and councillor watson oh
that's unanimous chair thank you
um well before we move on again can i
just um congratulate
councillor james on being re-elected as
a leader of the council with some
it is a big job it's certainly a job
that i would uh
shrink away from at this particular
moment but um congratulations ken and
keep up the good
thank you chair um just thank you for
your support it's definitely been
an interesting couple of years some of
the stuff has been external
we've got to deal with and we've dealt
with quite a bit internal
as far as i'm continuing well i'm just a
leader of a team
and that's a team of 36 plus the
officers so
um it is daunting but i'm enjoying it i
will be honest
and say i think we can go forward a lot
more we're in a good place now
let's go forward together so thank you
and if i could i would just like to
propose
that council hodgson continues as my
vice chair
okay really good job there thank you i
was just
just coming on to item eight but uh yeah
yes so claire hodgson has been uh
proposed
um for the deputy leader of the council
is there a second release
as chair councillor laws i would gives
me great pleasure to second
okay are there any other nominations
okay sandra if you could take that to
the vote please yeah thank you chad
councillor bowton uh for cancer brenton
or pencelebrite or
cancer brown or cancer bushby
or pencil christie or
pencil clark or pencil craigie
or penciller dart for
chancellor ford another day in paradise
for
counsellor cab paul councillor hackett
four councillor haims oh
cancer harding four pencil hawkins
for cancer hicks
sandra councillor hepburn's back as well
now oh
sorry cancer heppo
sorry i keep going in and out um yes
poor
thank you apologies cancer
a counselor hicks or counselor hobson
paul hence the harley or ansel hutchins
or councillor inch or
councillor james or councillor jones
or penciller langfoods
cancer laws or pencil leather
or pencil and lock four
handsome goth four pencil mackenzie
four chancellor manley paul
councillor newton paul councillor rossi
or and councillor watson oh
that's unanimous again chair thank you
very much um
and once again congratulations uh to
cancer hudson on being re-elected
um i think you've done uh a sterling job
in supporting
uh councillor james as um
as deputy uh deputy leader of the
council and
long may continue class well done thank
you
thank you i've enjoyed working this last
uh 18 months with councillor james
and i think going forward we've still
got quite a few challenges
to meet and i look forward to working
with you all
to deliver our vision and strategy for
torridge thank you thank you claire
okay item nine on your agenda is uh the
size
of committees and the terms of reference
which is pages five to twenty two
uh and to present that is the head of
legal and governance and the monitoring
officer
over to you stacy thank you chair and
yep so the next um
item is for full council to approve the
size of each of our committees and the
terms of reference
for each of our committees so as it
stands as set out
in the report um community and resources
have uh 12 seats audit and governance
six seats um together with one
non-elected
person um overview and scrutiny internal
have nine
plus up to three non-elected um overview
and scrutiny external also have nine
with free non-elected plans committee
nine
the joint crematorium committee five
and then we have the committees that
aren't required to be politically
proportionate
so that's licensing committee with ten
standards committee
seven plus up to two parish
representatives
the joint local plan working group have
seven
property and major projects working
group have four
and the climate change working group
have four
the terms of reference for each
committee are attached
um to the report going on from
pages six right through
to uh page 21.
and i think members will recall we've
recently reviewed the constitution
um no changes were proposed at that
stage but obviously
up for members to approve um these
tonight
[Music]
uh councillor brenton's hand up first i
think and then coaster james
thank you chair i just wanted to move
the recommendations i see there's one on
page five as well as the one on page
twenty three
boo's recommendations thank you coaster
james
um i'm happy to second them thank you
chair
okay uh it's been proposed and seconded
if there's no one else wishes to speak
i'll move some
on that document i'll ask sandra to take
it to the vote please
yeah thank you chair councillor bowton
for cancer brenton
or penciller bright
or penciller brown or
councillor bushby or chancellor christy
or penciller clark or cancer craigie
or penciller
poor pencil afford for
pencil cub or
pencilla hackett four penciller haims
or pencil harding or
pencil hawkins paul councillor heppell
four chancellor hicks
hensla hodgson or councillor harley
or ansel hutchins or
councillor inch for councillor james
or cancer jones or
cancer langford for pennsylvania
or councillor leather or
councillor lock four councillor mcgoff
four councillor mackenzie
four chancellor manly four
councillor newton four councillor rossi
or and councillor watson oh
that's unanimous chair
oh thank you for that sandra thank you
cancerous so
our next item on the agenda is the
allocation of seats to
political groups which is on pages 23 to
24
uh and also to receive ahead of uh
receive the report of hedden
head of legal and governance and
monitoring officer again over to you
stacy
thank you chair um again members not too
much for me to really say
in relation to this but uh the committee
seats are allocated on a politically
proportionate basis
based on the number of councillors per
group um the seat allocations have been
calculated um they should be on page 22
of your reports
um so it's the requirement of the
council's constitution
that these are approved by uh full
council at the agm
thank you stacey got two hands up
councillor james and councilman goff so
come to james first
um yeah sorry stacy i i was going to
propose it was allocated to group
leaders
um that we don't decide it tonight
um so i was going for that proposal um i
was a bit confused by what you just said
stacy
sorry uh sorry chair and just both of
them just talking to
the chief ex
um this is the they're not approving the
numbers of seats
on the committee sorry not not the
individual members on each community
which which can be delegated to the
group leaders
right okay my apologies uh
does the leader want to come back there
mr chairman well in that case i would
just approve the number of seats but i
thought that's what we've just done
yeah yeah an odd second that was shown
for me
yeah okay so again it's been proposed
and seconded
um that we accept the the report been
presented
um sandra can you take it to the vote
please oh sorry councillor brenton's got
his hand up
yeah sorry uh chair i'm a little bit
confused about what's on page 25 there
because it says uh
agree the membership on each committee
or delegate to group leaders well in the
past we've always delegated to group
leaders
but uh those committees could change in
other words so uh
and as some the leader pointed out we
should do that
uh separately yeah i think
that's the next agenda item i believe
that's correct okay it was just a report
went from
including 24. sorry okay okay confuse me
a bit but we'll get on to that
all right sandra has been proposed and
seconded could you take that into the
vote please
yes chad council about him at four
cancer brenton or cancer bright
or cancer brown or
cancer bush b or councillor christie
oh answer clark or
that's the craigie or
pencil of dart for
councillor ford what pencil gab
or pencil a hacker for
chancellor haynes
for councillor harding or
chancellor hawkins
james or jones
or pennsylvania langford for
pencil and laws or pencil and leather
or councillor lock or
pencil and mcgoff four councillor
mackenzie
four penciller manly for
pencilla newton four princely rossi
four pencil watson oh
unanimous chair thank you sandra
thank you members um okay moving now on
to item 11 on the agenda
membership of the committees which is on
pages
chair sorry it's tom here and just this
looks like there's some
issue with the page numbering that's
gone slightly scraped by a page so it's
page 24 to 26 for members for this
item you can just write 24 to 26 on your
agenda that will yeah
clear that okay we've got two
two hands up i see um councillor ranch
and councilman golf
council range first thank you chair
while we
this is what was confusing everybody
just now i think it just dedicate this
to the um
to the to the need members you know the
leaders of
each group to decide this we that's what
we usually done
it else it takes a long time in the
meeting so i propose that we just
delegate this to the uh
of each group counselor golf
famous chairman i'd like to second
cancer interest proposal that we
delegate to the group leaders to
allocate the seats thank you thank you
anyone else wish to speak before we go
to the vault
no okay sandra if you would please thank
you chad
councillor bowton oh chancellor brenton
or councillor bright
or councillor brown or
councillor bushby or ansel christie
oh pencil clark four
fragi or pencil of dart
or pencil ford for
a dab
or pencil harding or
penciller hawkins poor counselor
hutchins or cancer wrench
for penciller james or
pencil jones or
counselor langford for
cancer laws or cancer
chancellor newton
paul councillor rossi four
chancellor watson oh unanimous chair
thank you sandra okay item
12 on the agenda then is to election of
chairs and vice chairs of the various
committees and we start with
community and resources committee
have any any proposals for chair please
chair could i propose two thumbs up so
we're coaching james and councilman golf
yeah
well could i propose bob hicks please
for chat
you now okay i'm counselling my golf
famous chairman i'd like to second
casual james the pros of bob picks as
chairman of community resources
thank you councilor mallory councilman
goff just beat me to it
okay so councillor hicks has been
proposed and seconded
uh are there any other nominations for
chair
do we have to vote individually on these
stacy yes yeah i can't take chair and
vice chair and do the two together
oh no that has to be done individually
okay sandra if you could please yes
sorry cancel about in
pencil brenton or councillor bright
or that's lebron or
counselor bushby or pencil christy
or
for councillor hackett
or councillor haims
or pencilla harding or
councillor hawkins poor that's
apple
or penciller inch for
pencil james or pencil
jones or pencil langford
for councillor laws
that's lulato or counselor lock
or pencilling mcaf
or pencil mckenzie
poor pencil manly or
henson newton or pencilla rossi
or answer watson or
unanimous oh no sorry one abstention
chair
cassandra congratulations councillor
hicks you're once again
elected chair of cnr uh vice chair
we require now uh we've got councillor
jones
roundup thank you chair i'd just like to
propose counselor dermot mcdoff for this
he's done this role ably for the last
two years
and i hope in the spirit of inclusivity
that everyone will
continue to support him going forward in
this okay thank you
council hits your hands up i was gonna
propose anadar
okay thank you uh chris leather please
you've got your hand up
yeah i'd like to second anna dart please
okay and council harding i'd like the
second german golf please
okay so we've got two uh candidates been
proposed and seconded
um councillor amador and councillor
mcgough so we'll just take a vote
on on the first one on on
uh anadark please um sandra can we have
the show of hands
yeah sorry chair you can you can take
one vote for
for the both uh nominations and each
counselor can
indicate uh which counsellor they uh
wish to elect as vice chair
you can take one at a time we're both at
the same time both both at the same time
and counsellors can then indicate
which thank you so
uh councillor alador councillor dermot
mcgulff both been proposed and seconded
we'll go to the vote please sandra thank
you
council about him yeah i'm counselor
dominic mcgoff
clinton
councillor bright
counselor
counselor mcgoff oh scott came within my
room
councilor dart councillor hudson
councillor dart councillor harley
councilman mcgoff councillor hutchins
council mcguff councillor inch
country peter james
councillor jones councillor mcgoff
langford councillor dart
chancellor
councillor mcgough councilman gotham
thanks
mackenzie
councillor manly councillor dart
councillor newton councillor mcgough
and councillor watson council adult
that's one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen empty
five one two three four
five six seven
eight nine ten that's
22 for councillor dot and ten
for councillor mcgoff thank you sandra
congratulations cancer dart you've been
duly elected
um can i just take the opportunity to
thank uh councilman golf um he's done a
a very good job in standing him for uh
council hicks when uh
when the time has has been uh when it's
been called for and i thank him very
much for
for all his efforts but moving forward
then
with the next one is uh audit and
governance
getting used to these headphones i'd
like to propose phil hackett
thank you and chancellor laws i'd like
to second
phil phil packett please
thank you any other nominations
okay can we call that to take back to
the voting please
councillor bowton or councillor brenton
or councillor brian oh sorry sandra
should i have done the vice chair as
well at the same
time i should have should not no it's
separate votes chair
all right okay
thank you councillor bright or
councillor brown or hence
bushby or councillor christie
or pencillerclark or
answer craigie or
pencil darth
or pencil harding for
pencil hawkins for
the hippo
he's left the meeting sandra thank you
councillor hicks four but why did we go
through this rigmarole when there's only
one candidate
oh you have to do it you have to do it
pencil hudson or
pencil harley or
councillor hutchins or councillor inch
for councillor james
or penciller jones
four councillor langford or
penciller laws or councillor leather
or lock or
pencil mcgough or
mackenzie for
pencil manly
she's just lost connection sandra okay
thank you thank you tom councillor
newton
paul pencer rossi or
chancellor watson or
councillor manly back tom no she's not
sandra
we'll just finish it there okay thank
you it's actually an anonymous chair
thank you sandra okay we now come to
vice chair of auditing governance
sure please counselor i would
like to nominate somebody who's done
really well on
on the committee boarding governance and
that is councillor ruth craigey
okay i've got a second or please council
of watson
thank you watson any other nominations
no okay sandra over to you thank you
counselor or counselor brenton
or councillor bright or
counselor brown boy chancellor bushby
or chancellor christie oh
penciller clark four and silly craigie
it
has he rejoined no it doesn't look like
it's sandra
okay thank you tom councillor hicks
or cancer hudson oh
councillor harley or pencil hutchins
or penciller inch for
pencil james or pencil
jones or councillor langford
for pencil laws or
mackenzie for counsellor manly
i'll abstain i lost connection there
sorry i'm not sure what i'm voting for
okay newton paul
councillor rossi
thank you sandra congratulations to
those
members that have been duly elected um
the next one on the agenda is
plans committee i'd
counsellor bushby i'd like to
propose chris letter
thank you all right have a second
yes i would like to please second
account
counsellor leather for plans thank you
oh counselor
council carl you've got your hand up
everybody you're meeting councillor
clark
sorry sorry i'd like to nominate
uh councillor rosie lock thank
uh uncomfortable
are you all muted counselor barton i
would like to second counselor rose
milock
um she does an excellent job on plans
committee she has considerable
substantial experience okay thank you
very much
uh councillor hawkins i'd like to uh
propose
uh councillor peter christie thank you
uh do we have a second of the council of
christie
yeah council a second
sorry sorry i think councillor ford just
beat you um councillor brandon
okay chairman can i just have a word i
don't think peter couldn't
can have a chairmanship or or vice chair
[Applause]
because he's vice chair of council my
mistake
can i ask stacey can you clarify that
yes yes chair it's it's only the the
leader and the chairman can't be the
same person
of course he can't stand them yes yes
chad all right okay
okay that means we've got uh three
nominations then
for um sorry
christy yeah that's very kind of people
to nominate me i'm not sure i want to be
chairperson very much um i've only just
finished being chair of the bridge trust
on mayor of biddeford uh i've just been
vice chair of torridge
i think i can do without the plans thank
you very much though
okay so councillor chris is withdrawn
that means we've got
two nominations that's um council
leather
and councillor locke correct
there are no other nominations then
we'll take those two to the vote
sandra who are you please thank you
chair councillor bowton
uh councillor locke councillor brenton
abstain
councillor bright councillor leather
councillor brown dr leather
councillor bushby that's another
councillor christy councillor locke
that's the clark lock
councillor craigie counselor christy
i'm sorry counselor leather
okay pencil dart
counselor leather councillor ford
uh council lover councillor gab
councillor leather pencil hackett
councillor leather
james counselor leather
council harding councillor lock
councillor hawkins
ladder counselor harley
councillor locke councillor hutchins
and the lock councillor inch
closer together penciller
sure leather cancer jones
counselor lock counselor langford
abstain
counselling laws can't say like that
can't steal a leather absolute leather
okay it's little lock counts a lot
can oh
mackenzie councillor leather
councilor manly councillor lever
chancellor newton councillor lock
counselor rossie
councillor leather chancellor watson
council of leather
it's
chair that's 20 for cancer leather
10 for
councillor lock with two abstentions
one
elected chair of planning committee uh
vice chair now please
chair yes council leather um
thank you thank you for re-electing his
plans
chair we've got a very good committee i
hope we can keep a good committee
and to that end i'd like to propose
councillor margaret brown
as vice chairman she's very very
experienced
she's been a very good vice chair and
i'd like to propose council margaret
brown
thank you councillor clark you know
i'd like to propose councillor rosary
lock please
okay uh councillor bolton
you're meeting councillor belton yeah
i'd like to second council rosemary lock
please
okay thank you uh councillor james
could i second mark mcburn please thank
you okay
so we've got supposed to be doing that
yes i should have been actually but
never mind it's been done um
okay we've got uh two proposals for
uh vice chair so cancer
counselor brown and um
counselor lock so
we can do the two together here sandra
can't wait so um let's remember to vote
please
over to you sandra thank you chair
councillor bowdoin
uh councillor lock councillor brenton
elsa brown
councillor bright councillor brown
cats lebron councillor brown
councillor bushby hush lebron
councillor christie abstain
counselor clark councillor lock
cancer craigie counselor brown
councillor brown
councillor brown councillor harding
councillor locke councillor hawkins
i think i'm going to abstain
that's stellar hicks
counselor lock
pencil hudson councillor brown
councillor harley dancer lock
councillor hutchins how's it lock
councillor wrench denzel brown
councillor james thank you boom
pencil jones councillor lock
councillor langford councillor brown
councillor laws i'm celebrating
councillor leather councillor brown
councillor lock council or not
councillor mcgrath councillor lock
hanson mackenzie councillor brown
councillor manly councillor brown
councillor newton councillor lock
councillor rossie councillor brown
pencil watson councillor brown
one two three four ten twelve
17 for councillor brown and 11 for
councillor locke
with two abstentions thank you that's
councillor brown
duly elected as vice chair of planning
congratulations to the
council leather and coaster brown um
moving on then the next item is the
licensing committee
councillor mcgoff and councillor james
thank you much mr chairman mr chairman
i'd like to oppose
councillor michael clark as chairman of
the
licensing committee thank you
uh coaster james i'd like to propose uh
councillor jamie uh
sorry jamie mckenzie thank you been my
advice and done
chad several times in my absence okay
uh counselor knock please i'd like to
second the nomination for councillor
clark
okay um do we have a secondary for
councillor mckenzie
[Music]
your second nap call me
okay thank you very much uh counselor
i'm sorry that was councillor bright's
book then was it
uh yeah i was just gonna second as well
okay thank you
okay so we've got um councilor mckenzie
i'm sorry who was here it was the other
candidate again councillor
thanks for clark okay so often no
no further nominations uh sounded to
take that to the vote please
chair it's kirsty this time oh sorry
kirsty you're carrying a little man
sandra's having a drink and a rest is
she yeah that's it
thank you chair councillor belton yeah
councillor clark
councillor branton country mckenzie
councillor bright councillor mckenzie
councillor brown councillor mckenzie
councillor bushby christopher mckenzie
councillor christie councillor mckenzie
councillor clark oh councillor clark
thank you councillor craigie councillor
mckenzie
councillor dart councillor mackenzie
councillor ford councillor clark
councillor gub councillor mckenzie
councillor hackett councillor mckenzie
councillor haynes counselor mckenzie
councillor harding coaster clark
councillor hawkins councillor mckenzie
councillor hicks council mackenzie
councillor hudson councillor mackenzie
councillor hurley councillor clark
councillor hutchins clark
councillor inch coach mckenzie
councillor james council mackenzie
councillor jones councillor clark
councillor langford councillor mackenzie
councillor laws ancelory kenzie
councillor leather council mackenzie
councillor locke councillor clark
councillor mcgoff councillor clark
councillor mckenzie councillor mckenzie
councillor manley councillor mckenzie
councillor newton councillor clark
councillor rossi council mackenzie
councillor watson mckenzie thank you
so that's 22 for councillor mackenzie
and 10 for councillor clark
thank you kirsten mckenzie's duly
elected as chair of licensing
um the next sorry uh we've got
council mackenzie and then councilman
golf
i'm i was going to uh propose uh
councillor wiseman for
vice chair um yeah i know he's absent
from the meeting but he was consulted
beforehand and he's very willing to
uh step into that role so if i may
that's my proposal
you're muted councillor hackett
i beg your pardon um i was going to
second councillor wiseman
as proposed by councillor mckenzie thank
you thank you
councillor locke
i'd like to propose councillor clark as
last chair
okay can i have a second of a councillor
councilman golf
famous chairman i like the second
council of clark thank you thank you
point of view who's that
councillor jones chair yes captain john
thank you we are allowed to um propose
someone who isn't in the meeting aren't
we
we just don't want to appoint someone
who um we can't actually appoint
i believe we are i think we have
clarified that but stacy could you just
clarify that
yes chair you you can prepare someone
that isn't in the meeting i suspect if
if councillor um wiseman didn't want to
take the position then it'd have to come
back to full council for full council to
agree on alternative but
there's no difficulty with proposing and
nominating in his absence tonight
thank you okay so we've got uh two
nominations
um chris if you take that to the vote
please
thank you chair councillor belton yeah
councillor clark
councillor brenton
councillor brenton
muted sorry what were the two candidates
again sorry i was oh it's
councilor wiseman councillor
councillor wiseman thank you councillor
bright
councillor wiseman councillor brown
councillor wiseman councillor bushby
mr wiseman councillor christie
councillor wiseman councillor clark
yeah councillor clark
councillor craigie councillor wiseman
councillor dart councillor clark
councillor ford council wiseman
councillor harding
councillor clark
councillor hawkins councillor wiseman
councillor hicks councillor wiseman
councillor hudson councillor wiseman
councillor hurley councillor clark
councillor hutchins clark
councillor clark thank you councillor
inch
closer wiseman
councillor james councillor wiseman
councillor jones councillor clark
councillor langford councillor wiseman
counselor laws council wiseman
councillor leather councillor wiseman
councillor lock captains look clark
councillor mcgoff hazard
mckenzie answer the wise man
councillor manly councillor wiseman
councillor newton councillor clark
councillor rossi councillor wiseman
and councillor watson councilor wiseman
thank you
so that's 21 for councillor wiseman and
11 for
councillor clark okay thank you kirsty
so
councillor wiseman is duly elected vice
chair
of licensing thank you
okay the next one and there's a bit of a
bit of a grueling list but the next one
is
internal overview and scrutiny uh
council mcgoff's got a handout counselor
door and turns to the lock so it comes
from the golf first please
thank you mr chairman i'd like to pose
councillor simon newton to the road of
chairman
um after previous experience of
uh attending his meeting they've relied
on heavily for some advice and i think
be
the best person for the job thank you
councillor locke
i'd like to second that proposal
councillor newton thank you
and coachella hodgson
did you mean sorry sorry
okay i'd like to uh propose pete watson
well i was going to propose pete watson
actually but i'll second
sorry we got out of order didn't we
we did never mind okay
so we've got um councillor watson
uh proposed as chair and sorry
who was the other one again sorry amazon
okay they've both been proposed and
seconded
if there's no other nominations kirsty
will go to the vote please
thank you chair councillor belton
councillor
councillor brenton council watson
councillor bright watson
councillor brown actually watson
councillor bushby rachel watson
councillor christie councillor watson
councillor clark councillor newton
councillor craigie councillor watson
councillor dart
councillor watson councillor ford
council watson cats looked up
council watson councillor hackett
councillor watson councillor haines
councillor watson councillor harding
councillor newton councillor hawkins
councillor watson councillor hicks
oh sorry i switched off on somewhere
else um
councillor watson thank you councillor
hudson
councillor watson councillor hurley
chancellor newton councillor hutchinson
newton councillor langford
councillor watson councillor laws
angela watson councillor leather
watson thank you councillor lop
hamza newton hustler mcgoff
councillor newton councillor mckenzie
councillor watson councillor manley
councillor watson
councillor newton anthony newton
councillor rossie jonathan watson
councillor watson i think council watson
thank you
so that's 23 for councillor watson and
nine
for councillor newton thank you
kirsten so councillor watson duly
elected uh chair of
owen has internal and they come on to
the vice chair uh council watson
yeah chair can i uh propose tony inch
please
certainly you can uh chair i'd second
that
uh if i may councillor mckenzie okay
thank you council mckenzie
uh councilman golf famous chairman i'd
like to oppose councillor
simon newton
thank you uh councillor christie and
then councillor lock i'd like to propose
councillor peter holmes
thank you uh councillor lock i'd like to
second the proposal for all counts then
newton please
okay um do we have a second or for
consular
haims yeah
okay thank you council for beat me to it
okay so we have uh three
nominations now then correct
okay kirsty if you take that to the vote
please
thank you chair councillor belton
councillor houston
sorry was that councillor holmes
yes scarcity can i just interrupt you
we've got
someone shouting in the background i'm
not sure which counselor it was but
is it gone now i can't hear it now
could we ask everybody to mute unless
they're asked to speak please
that's not a bad idea thank you kirsty
thank you councillor brown councillor
inch
councillor bushby councillor wrench
newton councillor craigie
councillor holmes councillor dart
councillor inch councillor ford
councillor haynes
councillor gov councillor inch
councillor hackett councillor inch
councillor haynes councillor homes
councillor harding councillor newton
councillor hawkins councillor haines
tesla hicks clemson
councillor hudson councillor inch
councillor hurley johnson newton
councillor hutchins how's it newton
councillor inch council wrench
councillor james councillor
councillor james councillor newton
councillor langford councillor haynes
councillor laws counselor inch
counselor leather councillor inch
councillor lock downs then newton
council macguff newton
councillor mckenzie councillor inch
councillor manly councillor inch
counselor newton councillor newton
councillor rossi councillor newton
councillor watson
councillor watson
what are you add to me council ranch
thank you
okay so that's 10 for councillor newton
8 for councillor haines and 14 for
councillor wrench
thank you kirsten so uh counselor
uh inch is duly elected vice chair of
uh over room scrutiny internal
okay pencilers
okay so this next item on the agenda
then
is external overview and scrutiny
committee
um so we're calling for a chair there
on the device here so nominations for
joe comes to james
could i nominate councillor joe manley
please
thank you i'd like to second that if i
could please
any other or coachella langford yeah
thank you chair um
i i think it's important in the interest
of proper scrutiny that the chair should
not be a member of the league group so
to that end i'd like to propose
councillor brenton as chair of external
ons
we all know he has he would bring huge
experience to the role
thank you thank you do you have a second
of course with brenton
yeah i'd like to second i'm sorry i
can't put my hand up at the moment
okay thank you uh
you've taken your hand down country
question that's because it's been second
did i take it
yes thank you sorry who was that
secondary
uh counselor craigie that's really crazy
sorry country queer
i didn't quite recognize your voice
there okay so we've got
two candidates both been proposed and
seconded
um after the northern nominations i'll
ask you to take the rule please
thank you chair councillor about him who
was the who was
that who was the other um councillor
manly please councillor brenton
councillor brenton councillor bright
councillor brenton councillor brown
flynn
councillor craigie councillor brenton
carla dart councillor manly
councillor ford councilman manly
councillor dub councillor manley
councillor hackett councillor manley
councillor haines answer brenton
councillor harding councillor manley
councillor hawkins councillor brenton
councillor hicks councillor manly
councillor hudson councillor manley
councillor hurley counselor manly
councillor hutchins councillor brendan
chancellor inch doctor manly
councillor james councillor manly
councillor jones councillor brenton
councillor langford councillor brenton
councillor laws councillor manley
manly councillor mcgough
i'll abstain thank you
councillor mackenzie councillor manly
councillor manly
uh councillor manley councillor newton
councillor manly councillor rossi
councillor manley councillor watson
councillor manley thank you
okay so that's 22 for councillor manly
nine for councillor brenton and one
obsession chair
thank you kersey uh so councillor manley
is duly elected
chair of external overview and scrutiny
which brings us all now to the vice
chair
and we've got two hands up councillor
manley and councillor locke
i'd like to propose council cheryl
cottle honking please chair
thank you councillor lock i'd like to
propose
council steve harding please okay
and chair council laws i would like to
uh
second uh cheryl honkin
okay thank you kessler golf
i'd like this the second rose locks
proposer piece
okay so we've got pencil cutter honking
and
was it council harding was that yeah
okay
okay there's been no other nominations
then unless there are many others we'll
ask kirsty to take it to the vote please
thank you chair councillor belton uh
council harding
councillor brenton counselor harding
councillor bright lakota honking
councillor brown outside of the honkin
council bushby coastal coddle honking
councillor christie councillor honking
councillor clark uh councillor harding
councillor craigy councillor cottle
hunting
councillor dart
[Music]
honking
hawkins councillor cottle honking
councillor hicks councillor cuddle
hunkin
councillor hudson councillor cottle
hunkin
councillor hurley chancellor harding
councillor hutchins councillor harding
councillor wrench grocery honking
councillor james uh councillor cottrell
honkin
councillor jones councillor harding
councillor langford councillor cottle
hunkin
councillor laws counselling cottle
hankin
councillor leather council cardinal
honking
councillor locke captain harding
councillor mcgough to steve hardin
councillor mackenzie councillor cottle
pumpkin
councillor manley councillor costell
hunkin
councillor newton councillor harding
councillor rossi councillor cottle
hunkin
councillor watson councillor cuttle
hunting
so it's 22 for councillor cottle hunting
and 10th
councillor harding thank you kirsty
so councillor cottle honking newly
elected vice chair of
overview uh scrutiny external
thank you very much for that counselors
okay the last one on the list
i hope anyway is uh a standards
committee
nominations for chair and vice chair so
chair first of all please
councillor hudson
council hudson and council watson you're
me to council hudson
i'd like to nominate councillor
nick laws thank you
i'd like to second that chair thank you
coach
watson any other nominations
okay we'll take that to the vote now
please
thank you chair thank you councillor
belton
or councillor brenton
councillor brenton
councillor bright
cancer brown council bushby
or councillor christie oh
councillor clark or councillor craigie
or counselor dart
four councillor gov
four councillor ford again
councillor hackett four councillor haims
oh
councillor harding four
councillor hawkins ball
councillor hicks for
councillor hudson
councillor hurley or
councillor hutchins or councillor inch
or councillor james for
councillor jones or councillor langford
four councillor laws
council leather or councillor lock
boar councilor mcgough
boliv stein thank you
council mackenzie four
councillor manly four
councillor newton councillor rossi
four four
councillor watson thank you is
councillor brenton back
yes four thank you
so it's thirty four one against and one
abstention chair
thank you clearly councillor laws
is duly elected chair of standards
committee in the command of vice chair
council rules
uh yes uh i would like to propose
councillor jude gub
please thank you uh coachella mcgolf
thank you i'd like to propose counselor
michael clark please
thank you councillor james
you're muted counselor james
sorry um i'd like to second currency
thank you do we have a second or for
uh councillor sorry council harding i'd
like to second uh darwin's uh proposal
michael clark
thank you very much uh councillor
harding yes
thank you okay so we have are there any
other nominations
okay so we've got councillor jude gob
and councillor harding proposed as
vice chair of standards so sorry
we've got councillor glove and
councillor clark not councillor harding
oh sorry yeah uh over to you kirsty
please
thank you chair councillor belton hello
yeah uh council
councillor councillor brenton
council governor councillor bright
councillor dub councillor brown
doctor cub councillor bushby
angela
dart council
councillor ford well given what a choice
abstain
council look up council counselor
councillor hackett councillor god
councillor haines councillor garden
councillor harding councillor clark
councillor hawkins you're all upstate
councillor hicks come to the gab
councillor hodson councillor gab
councillor hurley clark
councillor hutchins county clerk
councillor inch coach
councillor james come suck up
councillor james councillor clark
councillor langford councillor gub
councillor laws actually cut
councillor leather councillor gob
councillor lock councillor clark
councillor mcgoff councillor clark
councillor mackenzie councillor gov
councillor manley councillor gov
councillor newton councillor clark
councillor rossi
that's 20 for councillor gob
10 for councillor clark and two
abstentions chair
thank you kirsten so that means that
councillor
jude gobb has been elected vice chair of
standards committee along with nick laws
as chair so thank you very much
countries for that
that really brings us to the end of that
marathon session of
certainly watching democracy in action
there i think but uh
thank you very much for that um the next
item on the agenda
moving swiftly on bypass eight is item
13
uh to receive the report of head of
legal and governance and the monitoring
officer
is this just to accept stacy
chair it is but just briefly um before
we go to the recommendations
um there is a a type o on page 49. so
the scheme of delegations was approved
by
members um through the working group and
then it was brought to full council um
at the moment we've got revenue and
benefits under the head of communities
in place and whilst i'm quite tempted to
leave it there that's wrong it needs to
be amended under the
head of legal and governance so that
there's a few typos in in here but
effectively the scheme of delegation is
what's already been approved by members
previously through the working group so
just to assure members um we're just
reading through to check for any other
errors but
um yep so members need to approve under
the constitution again
okay thank you councillor dart
thank you it's just um i've picked up on
a couple things
um but the one that really springs to
mind
is under waste on page 42
and this is actually i suppose aimed at
our chief exec
um subject to a meeting that we had at
cleveland recently
it says without prejudice to the
generality of the above
the power to determine whether a place
at which waste is situated
is so isolated as to make the cost of
collection unreasonably high
um i wonder
i'd like assurances that basically it
wasn't possible for the chief exec
to um or or whoever's in charge of waste
to make those determinations without
consulting with
um the ward member
okay can i have a response please
chief exact would you like to respond to
that um
just reading it a second okay which
paragraph was it um
um yeah so it's 35a i just i probably
over looked into it but i just wanted
assurances based on recent
um issues that we've had
i think in practice and the reality is i
think yes we of course we would consult
with the ward member
i can't think of an occasion where we've
actually done that i mean we
i think what we do do is ask people to
take it to
specific designated collection points if
it's too difficult
or too expensive and that that's
happened in the past but we'll always do
our best
and consult with the residents concerned
there are obviously a few isolated areas
within torridge
where it does happen but of course in
reality we would consult
councillor dart is that sufficient
answer for you
yes it is i'm just re-reading another
thing that i circled to see if it still
bothers me um
sorry bear with me
no i think that's it sorry thank you
okay
thank you are there any other comments
before i propose that we accept this
document
okay so i propose sorry sorry sorry
can i just have can i just read this out
again
so we're on page 48 and
it's um b6 number five
and basically it says the head of legal
and governance monitoring officer and
senior management team
um it says to undertake
any roles actions or measures including
power to consider and determine
any matter allocated to the head of
legal and governance
and monitoring officer or senior
management team
within the constitution whether
specifically identified
in the delegated powers to officers or
otherwise
now as i interpret that that basically
means that
legal and governance and monitoring
officer can basically
overturn everything um am i interpreting
that
right uh chair can i assist
um no i've got statutory functions as
has the section 151 officer that
specifically sat out in statute
so um david says for example
i can't think of example sorry it's been
a lot he's here
um but i you know one of my functions is
for example was to pull out lawful
activities to monitor um the
counsellor's behavior
so but reality is no we wouldn't
overrule every other function
it's i've can't think of an occasion
that's happened but um we've got
statutory functions and councils have to
have a monitoring officer and have to
have a section 151 officer so that
that's the reality of what that means
councillor dar isn't
i wouldn't want to even if we could but
you're not going to rule everything
okay you happy with that concert yeah
thank you
thank you thank you for watching yes
cancer
yeah no um stacey's here and she's all
about chancellor's behavior
this is pertinent um just um i want this
clarified
if the council has got a complaint
against another counselor this is purely
hypothetical
as i understand it she is the monitoring
officer
so what i would like to ask her would
that therefore be appropriate
if two other senior officers are in that
room at the same time
when those complaints are being
discussed because i don't think they
should be
and that's what happened to me so could
she answer please with all the public to
hear
sorry cancer ford i don't understand the
question are you saying if you've got a
complaint
about me or one of my other officers i
said a counselor against the councillor
you're a monitoring officer that
counselor when discussing the complaint
should only be seeing the monitoring
officer
not number one and number two in the
room at the same time as they were when
i made a complaint some months ago
please terrify that's what i don't
recall a situation where you made a
complaint to me and number one and
number two were in
the room i've always made it clear that
if somebody wants to submit a complaint
to me as monitoring officer
they're entitled to talk to me about
that confidentially
and i i always maintain that so i i
cannot think of an occasion where
someone has discussed a monitoring
officer complaint with me where either
the chief executive
or head of community places have been
there unless that person has requested
their presence within the room
well i'm just making a statement of fact
when i made a complaint
it was brushed aside because you didn't
consider about
a public perception reference one of the
complaints was about a plan
application and you just simply said to
me with the other two in the room
i can't do anything about that wouldn't
make any difference because the vote was
only one vote
which is absolute boulder dash but
number one and number two is in that
room
when i should have been there with just
you
okay okay can i just
come in here the agenda item that we're
talking about is a scheme of delegation
i understand what counselor is coming up
where he's coming from here
and it may well be a very legitimate um
don't worry it's just a question
of time i just don't think no is the
right time to do that
not fair enough tomorrow's good enough
for me sir thank you
thank you um so are we
if there's no other uh questions of of
this document um i propose that we
accept it do we need to
do that need to go to vote on that
yeah yes shall we say okay i'll propose
it
i'll second our second that counts in
luck thank you
councilor mandy and then councillor
newton have their hands up
i was just seconded to
okay i'll move to accept that then it's
been proposed and seconded can we go to
the vote percy please
thank you chair councillor belton for
councillor brenton
councillor brenton
councillor bright
four councillor brown
councillor bushby or councillor christie
councillor clark four
council craigie paul councillor dart
four councillor ford
again says there's no governance at
torres i want it noted but it will
because it's on zoom thanks
thank you for zoom counselor cup
for councillor hackett
councillor haynes
councillor harding
hudson or councillor hurley
or councillor hutchins or
chancellor inch or councillor james
for councillor jones
or councillor langford
for council of laws
or councillor leather
councillor locke paul councillor mcgoff
council mackenzie four
councillor manly paul
councillor newton oh
councillor rossi or
councillor watson
councillor watson thank you is
councillor brenton back
no his camera's still off kirsty thank
you so that's
34 and one against chair
thank you kirsten that's newly carried
thank you
okay item 14
is a substitution scheme which says
pages 58 and 61 but it's actually 57 to
60 from what i can gather
um and to receive a report of the head
of legal and governance
stacy is there very much you want to say
on this let's not chair this the current
scheme of delegation is set out
it's on my page 60 on on the paper copy
um so again full council needs to
approve that or not approve as as the
case may be
okay coach hobson i'd like to
propose that this is delegated to group
leaders
to agree the membership on outside
bodies okay i'll second that
chair this is the substitution
this is approving the substitution
scheme i'm sorry 60 sorry councillor
hodgson
it's wishful thinking that you went
ahead you went ahead
right well i'll propose then from this
year that we accept this
um substitution scheme can i have a
second or for that please
yes i reckon that counts a lot cancel a
lock okay
counselor james you've got your hand up
no i was just going to second it that
was all
okay kirsty please take it to the ball
thank you chair councillor belton at
four
councillor brenton
councillor bright four
cancer brown or councillor bushby
or councillor christie or
councillor clarke or councillor craigie
or councillor dart
for councillor ford
he's left the meeting kirsty okay thank
you councillor gov
paul councillor hackett or
councillor haynes or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins or
councillor hicks or councillor hodson
for cancer hurley or
councillor hutchins or cancer inch
for sure councillor james
or councillor jones or
councillor langford
council of laws or cancer leather
poor counselor lock
councilman goff four councillor
mackenzie
for councillor manly ball
councillor newton oh councillor rossi
for councillor watson
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you kirsten
uh item 15 and membership with outside
bodies
um council i'm a golf first and then
councillor jones
thank you i'd like to propose we
delegate as the group leaders please
mr chairman thank you thank you
councillor jones
thank you chad i'm happy to second
councilman we've got from that the only
point i'd like to raise
um is no slice at all on on councillor
hodson but
um it does say on there that she is our
representative
on the homeless charity harbour i say
this isn't something i
know a great deal about but i just
wonder whether it make more sense
that our lead member for homelessness um
is our representative on that body thank
you
thank you uh councillor hurley and then
councillor wrench
thank you chair i know that the um devon
rail forum isn't shown on that uh
list and i'm the council representative
on there
uh okay so is that likely to be added
then uh
steve or stacy is that uh a group that
we
would normally have on there um chair i
can't recall if it's normally on there
but
if it's uh an external group that should
be on there then we can add it
thank you um councillor inch and then
council hudson
and then comes with james yeah thank you
chair
just to note that when it goes to uh
group leaders that
uh just to check that these outside
groups are still operating because i can
see
at least one or two on there that's not
operated that integrate
is not operated um so you know just to
make sure that these outside bodies are
upgraded
some some years ago when we had these
outside bodies
we did look at them because we had a um
a great big list of them and
half of them weren't operating you know
so just to make sure that
uh these are operated and perhaps um
we could add some more if if if it is
necessary
okay thank you it's a good point um
cancer hudson
you're mutually counselling i'm not i've
taken it off
i welcome councillor jones's comments
and
he's echoing what i've already shared
with my fellow independent members
um during the last week or so to say
that
it isn't appropriate although i have
extensive housing knowledge
um councillor clark is far better
equipped with his role
to actually sit as our representative
and
i put that forward to councillor james
to say that
we should consider that when group
leaders meet
to discuss the allocation of these
responsibilities
so thank you i've already acknowledged
that so thank you very much
okay go through james
your mute counselor james
right on my list i've already deleted
councillor hodgson
not um not for any other reason and and
put
counselor michael clark there because we
agreed that was more appropriate
and coaster hurley we did have a
discussion about this some while ago and
i know cancer hurley
is representing us on the devon road
forum so that will be added
and again i think there's one of the
ones i do that may not be operating or
certainly they're not cooperating if not
if they're still operating if you see
what i mean so we will be checking the
list
and um then we will be going through it
again before it
is finally published okay thank you
councillor clark
what i've done uh yes just to say that
i i do a lot of work with um
uh several homeless charities within
our um tdc so
i'm happy to accept um
if that's okay thank you councilman
clark you're saying to be the ideal
candidate
thank you uh okay
so i'll move that we accept i'm sorry
councillor inch
is it isn't that one of the um charities
that's uh
done to the war harbor i believe it is
i believe they're not functioning
anymore so that needs to be checked
that's what i mean these need to be
checked out yeah
well as scheduler james has said all of
these will be
looked at so yes you're absolutely right
um okay for the further speakers i'll
move then that we accept
this uh membership of outside bodies
that will be looked at by the
well sorry
yeah yep chad you've had a proposal in a
second uh
for it to be decided by the group
leaders yeah okay
so we need to take a vote on that kirsty
please
thank you chair councillor belton for
councillor brenton
councillor bright paul councillor brown
borah councillor bushby moore
councillor christie oh councillor
or councillor craigie oh
councillor dart four councillor gub
four councillor hackett or
councillor haynes or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins or
councillor hicks or councillor hodgson
for councillor hurley or
councillor hutchins or councillor inch
or councillor james or
councillor jones or councillor langford
for council of
counselor leather or counselor lock
or counselor mcguff
my apologies for thank you councillor
mackenzie
four councillor manley or
councillor newton or councillor rossi
for councillor watson
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you kirsty
okay then over the page to uh item 16 on
the agenda
uh lead members which is page 67-68
is there any changes on this or or do we
take them on block
i'm chaseley joey to just briefly report
uh i've just got council of james to
come in first council james first
well um steve can go first and ask
someone
all right okay okay thank you thank you
thank you um so we just put the the list
up on the page so apologies for the
the report and a bit of the the report
dropped off the end unfortunately
um so councillors will recall that um
the lead members
schedule was updated slightly back in
february of this year
and the the tables on the screen for you
to consider
and it's for members either to con
either to
approve the same list as it's on the
screen or
make any amendments as you so wish and
yes councillor bushby
chair you can approve them on block if
you if you so wish
thank you uh country james i was just
gonna add what
uh to what steve said is that we did
approve these only a couple of months
ago
so they're fine um what i would say is
that
they're a mix of uh there's no political
alliance with any of them i hear
statements like are we a member-led
council or
an officer led as far as i'm concerned
member set strategy
lead members help officers get that
strategy into place and move it forward
and we expect officers to carry out and
what i will say
even on friday i do hear some very good
reports
about one uh lead member which is not
unusual
i do get those comments and it does seem
to be working well so i'd just like to
thank all lead members
now that the way they are working with
officers and vice versa the way officers
are working with lead members i think
it's part of the team spirit
so thank you very much okay well i don't
believe we've had
any um any lead members
indicate that they're not willing to
stand so
that being the case um i'll propose that
we
accept them on block as presented i have
okay so it's been proposing second date
can we go to the vote kirsty please
thank you chair councillor belton uh for
councillor brenton or councillor bright
or councillor brown or
councillor bushby or
councillor christie oh councillor
clark paul
councillor craigie paul councillor dart
four councillor gub
paul councillor hackett for
councillor haynes or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins paul
kessler hicks or councillor hudson for
councillor hurley or councillor hutchins
councillor inch for councillor james
or councillor jones
four councillor langford four
councillor laws or councillor leather
or councillor lock or
council mcgough
or councillor mackenzie
for councillor manly ball
councillor newton or councillor rossi
boar chancellor watson
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you kirsty
okay item 17 councillors allowances
um i've i've been in discussion with
them
the leader um over this issue and it is
proposed
that items actually 17 and 19
are deferred um for to await
uh further information and clarification
on a number of items that
are in the document uh counselor
yes thanks chair well i just wanted to
ask on the council allowances one
if it's deferred and it mentions in the
report about a review
can we have some date of when this
review is likely to take place
you shut it down yeah
sorry got cancer hutchins before we get
an answer can sergeants
sorry and i'm just gonna ask that with
the independent review
um is there any way that counselors
could maybe have some input
before the independent review or at
least to give them some
some feedback um there's a few bits we
have discussed in inside it
as a group and i think maybe some um
input from counsellors
not necessarily the full review but some
input towards towards that review
i see no reason why not but um yes
coachella james
yeah i'll just confirm that because i
read the report
there's a couple bits in it that mystify
me a little bit
so i think i have mentioned two other
group leaders
that um we do need to look at it again
um
and that's obviously at the moment i
can't give you any timetable on it
but we will be looking at it again and
bringing it forward to a future meeting
so that'll be looked out through the
group leaders meetings
well i think we need to decide all
independently i think um i'll talk to
the chief exec
and to the monitoring officer about how
we take forward comments
um and work with it it seems to be
slightly
a bland statement and when you read it
there's a little bit of stuff that's a
bit ambiguous
so i think um we just need a bit of time
to look at it and then bring it
back to the council on how we're going
to handle it
so councillor archangel's comment about
um comments on it um who does he
address them to the chief exec um well
that's what
we've sent a note on because obviously
whether we do it through the groups
uh and the group leaders will do it
straight to
the chief exec or the monitoring officer
i think it's
rather than make decision tonight on
that yeah i'm not
that sure um but i think we do need to
have a vehicle
of getting members views on it okay
thank you councillor jones
thank you chair i was just wondering
whether we could set up a working group
to consider the cancer allowances as
well as the working practices of the
council
as we move forward with the potential
for more zoom meetings and things i've
said this before
and i think that the allowances and our
working practices should be looked at
in tandem and hopefully we can modernize
and
make more efficient the way we do
business both in terms of
time but also expenses and money that
we're spending so i would welcome a
working group to
look at this
okay thank you councillor jones um
councillor christie yes um a working
group
might be a good idea personally i
was very glad to see something i've been
banging on about for years about
vice chairman getting allowances would
it be possible if a working group is set
up could we have some figures
on how often uh vice chairman have had
actually to stand in
for chairman because that happens fairly
rarely
in my um knowledge and i do wonder we
should be paying those allowances i see
this report is now
two years old yeah we need to do
something about it yeah
okay um uh we've got four hounds up no
counselor each first and then council
hutchins
thank you chair well you know i've been
going on for best for a long time i have
talked with the uh
with with the chief executive about this
um
before you know i i don't think i think
this should be taken out of councillor's
hands really
because um as you know some counsellors
some councils don't work like this at
all counselors don't have a vote
they just um have a system where
whatever the amount of money
um or the the allowance or the
percentage goes up with their employees
um that's what the coasters get so if
the officers get two percent sort of the
coasters
and it's taken out of our hands all
together then and we haven't got a vote
on it because this comes up
every year and you know it's like it's
like the counselor is focusing
for their own pay rights and it doesn't
go down very well in the local press or
anything like that
it's done it's like that for years and
demon county council has gone down this
route now they don't we you know like
them county councillors don't vote for
the rights
um it's determined by what
uh the officers get yeah i think
it will go for a working group would be
a good idea i think
okay uh clearly what you've said is a
good idea but that wouldn't
answer the question that counselor
christie is just raised
as to whether deputies get that so
possibly a working group is the way
forward but councillor hutchins and then
councillor jones
um councillor christie mentioned down
vice chairs
one of my thoughts was that you actually
pay um for the chairmanship of a meeting
on a monthly basis
so whoever actually chairs that meeting
gets the payment for the chairmanship
so if they do have a stand in that month
uh by the vice chair where the vice
chair gets paid
so basically the the annual fee for a
chairmanship
is split into a um into a monthly
payment
for meetings just an idea thank you
um councillor jones and then
steve hurst on an item that
i was going to defer but
thank you for letting me come back in
chair can i can i make a formal proposal
then that we create a working group to
look at this
um and and to start giving this some
thoughts soon
so i look for a seconder on that please
okay
council hodgins is second to that okay
um
before we go to the vote i'll bring in
uh the chief exec first and then
councillor hacker
okay and i was only only gonna say what
councillor jones uh pointed out uh we
started the conversation with the item
being uh
deferred to a future meeting and you
know it's been debated and you've got
uh proposals and recommendations to do
something
yeah that was something i was going to
point out but obviously you now have
a i do feel uncomfortable with that um
councillor hackett yes thank you very
much chair
um i don't think it's workable that you
have a sort of ad hoc
month by month who's chaired the
meetings or not payment because
um i just give cite the case of auditing
governance
you have regular audit reports come in
you discuss it where necessary with
the person who's submitting the audit
report and
the officer involved the chair and vice
chair
of auditing governance also sits on an
external
body devon audit partnership and
there is a greater pool of knowledge
required
ongoing than just simply sitting at the
table and sharing the meeting i think
that's got to be taken on board
yeah thank you very much chair thank you
i did start off by saying this item you
know was
um recommended for deferral i i still
think it should be
councillor jones your suggestion of a
working group i think it was cancer
jones wouldn't know
yes could that
possibly wait until we've actually got
the revised document come through
so that at least it gives people an
opportunity to you know to come back
with another document
if you still feel at that point that a
working group is required
then so be up i mean could we not send
the revised document
to the working group obviously this can
be a working group of
as many people of as many political
persuasions as i want to be there
um and i say i think i think it's just
about time that we we look at this and
also the way in which we conduct our
business and i think it would be a shame
to not
take this opportunity and actually go
forward and do something about it
so i i would like to say
okay thank you councillor james well
the only thing is joining the two
together um i'll be slightly concerned
so obviously we're awaiting
um the court judgment on zoom meetings
and where the government's going to go
with that
um i think this is a specific issue of
whether we actually pay
advice uh deputy chairs or vice chairs
um
and as i said i one reason to ask for
a deferral was that there was some stuff
in there i thought we should explore
further
now whether that's in a working group or
quite how we do it
i haven't thought that far ahead to be
honest um so
i think i i don't think we should
propose a working group tonight i think
as i said earlier that we need property
to discuss this and i'm happy to discuss
it with other group leaders
about how we actually deal with it if it
is a working group that's fine
but so often we get working groups that
just become working groups
so i prefer we stick with deferral to
that for tonight
okay coachella golf and then councilman
very much mr chairman um i support
cancer jones here
this gives the council's opportunity at
the working group
to air any concerns they've got or any
ideas they want to put forward which
actually benefit
the review coming forward then we then
it feels like we've had a member input
into this
i feel this is important for everybody
my personal reviews are
that no chair or vice chair should be
paid a penny
you get an allowance from the council
anyway and it's public first and
to be honest it's not political thing
this is just transparency for me i
i don't believe that a chair or a vice
church get a penny then we'll see the
best people for the job
and then we get the job done properly
okay i just have a favorite issue thank
you don't believe you should pay for the
jobs
for that one there that's my view but
working your support mr chairman thank
you
thank you councillor hicks
thank you mr chairman uh the proposal as
on the paper in my opinion is right
another working group at this stage is
just another
talking shop if you're not careful yeah
let them get on get a pet get the facts
and get the paper and we have a good
debate in full council
and sort it once and for all a working
group that wanted germans they'll what
uh it'll just waste time
yeah okay thank you council hodgson
and then hopefully councilman james
being the last one council olson
well i i agree with councillor hicks i
think
we do need to have a full debate and we
need to be prepared
for some to take into consideration some
of the options that have been
proposed tonight but i don't think this
is the time
or place to be saying what we should do
without proper thought and preparation
before a meeting
we've had a report presented which we've
identified
lacks in the detail that we need um
and a deferral is the sensible way
forward when we've all had time to
consider
all the facts there are obviously um
several councillors who have considered
this
and have come to their conclusions um
and are mindful to make recommendations
tonight
but for those of us who've considered
the report as it stands
and have identified it as lacking in the
information we need i don't think it's
appropriate that we go forward making
recommendations tonight
this is uh not the time nor the place
thank you councillor james your last
word yeah i would just agree with
coaster hits and councillor hobson
and i sincerely whether chairman are
paid or not
or vice chairman they are the best
people for the job
and um doing a proper job um regardless
of any political allegiance
so thank you chair okay so
counselor jones do you still stand by
your
um proposition that we have uh
a working group or would you like to
withdraw that waiting
uh clarification on the document no chad
i say i still like to stand by that and
i would like to look at the way and this
which this council operates so i'd like
to put that to the vote if that's okay
with you okay
and the second are was
okay kirsty if you could take that to
the vote then as to whether we have
a working group set up to look at
um the uh councillors allowances
so if you're voting in support of the
working group
obviously yes if you're voting against
that obviously no
okay thank you chair councillor belton
for councillor brenton
gates councillor bright
or councillor brown against
councillor bushby against councillor
christie
again councillor clark
against councillor craigie
abstain councillor dart
against councillor dub
against councillor hackett
against councillor haines again
councillor harding
abstain councillor hawkins
four councillor hex
against councillor hudson
against councillor hurley
abstain councillor hutchins
councillor inch against
councillor james councillor jones
for councillor langford
against council of laws
changed
councillor leather against
councillor locke four
councillor mcguff for democracy
yes council mackenzie
against councillor manly
oh sorry we've gotten stuck um against
councillor newton abstain
councillor rossi
four and i didn't
sorry i didn't catch councillor rossi's
boar
thank you
so that's 8 4 19 against and for
abstentions chair thank you kirsty so
motion is lost so obviously the uh
we'll just have to wait now until the
report comes back to us whether
it's probably recommendations um thank
you
a bit of a long-winded deferral but
never mind uh
pub number 18 on the agenda is public
spaces protection order
uh pages 77-98 to receive the report of
the public health and
housing manager that's me
uh chair thank you very much good
evening ladies and gentlemen um
tonight i'm seeking approval to
designate
a public space protection order a pspo
in relation to antisocial behavior and
street drinking controls in a defined
area
of biddeford and ps bureaus
are a legal tool to stop um individuals
or groups committing anti-social
behavior or nuisance
in a public space that is detrimental to
the local communities quality of life
and it's essentially a bylaw and the psp
must meet a number of tests and those
tests are given
in the report but um essentially that
behavior
or the behavior being restricted has to
be having or likely to have
a detrimental effect on the quality of
life of those in locality
it needs to be persistent or continuing
in nature
it needs to be unreasonable and it needs
to justify the restrictions imposed
and psps can be enforced by a police
officer
and police community support officers
and specifically
authorized and accredited council
enforcement officers and that would be
members of my neighborhood enforcement
team
a breach of a pspo is a criminal offence
um
and that can result in a fixed fancy
notice of 100 pounds
and on breach of the order alternatively
a fine of up to
1 000 pounds can be imposed by a court
on conviction of a breach
so the the proposed wording of the order
is given
uh in the report and relates to the
consumption of alcohol within the
designated area
and the surrender of containers
containing or belief to contain our
alcohol in addition it creates a new
provision of
requiring individuals to leave the
designated area and not return
within six hours of being instructed to
leave
it also creates provisions around
urination and defecation within the uh
within the designated
designated area and committing
anti-social
aggressive or intimidating behavior
um this is a significant expansion
on the current street drinking psp in
biddeford um both in the range of
the provisions it covers as well as the
the area of the town that it relates to
and the current provisions um cover the
just the key
land of israel walk and victoria park
there is a requirement as part of
bringing in the provisions
um that the ps4 ps bureaus
are made only after consultation with
specified individuals
and as well as the public and the full
results
of that public consultation is given in
the report but just to summarize
um out of this 77 responses uh received
via the web form
87 think the pspo is justified
88 strongly agree um or agree with the
restrictions
79 agree with the suggested boundary
83 percent of people think the pspo will
have a positive impact on those
who live and work in biddeford
um i would also draw members attention
to uh
the response and from the police and the
comments from
and emma lefort who's the torridge um
acting inspector
um part of her comments were that um i
hope
i am wholeheartedly in favor of this
proposal
which if implemented will collectively
enable police and the council
to deal with anti-social behaviour in a
much wider area
as detailed in the associated map she's
also
provided and the number of incident logs
that have been reported
to the police um amounting to 167
in 2019 um and 162 logs
in 2020 and it is of course um has to be
noted that the numbers given for 2020
and covers a substantial period of
lockdown as well
um i i do have to point out the two
areas of
emma's comments relating to the coverage
of the designated area
uh and a request from the police and
that the provisions
also be extended to include intoxicating
substances
as well as alcohol and this has been
taken forward
um to the final recommendation to
members
um i did mention about the prescribed
tests bring
in a pspo and the report does consider
the test required by the legislation and
as a consequence
um it is our opinion that these tests
are met
and as such we're putting forward these
recommendations uh for approval by this
committee
and but however that does include the
amendments uh recommended by the police
and as a response to the consultation
process
um in putting forward these proposals
we're not saying that the provisions
will mean an
end to the recognised issues of
anti-social behaviour in biddeford
however it does provide an additional
enforcement option
for police and council officers
and be one of a range of tools available
to us to tackle these issues
and we recognize that in implementing uh
the
disorder should members see fit to do so
and there will be an increasing
expectation for the police and the
council
to respond to the problems we do
understand that and we will
we will meet that we are currently
pursuing a number of funding
opportunities that will
will help with this and if members are
so minded
we can bring a response plan back to a
future meeting so that members can have
a full
uh um uh full understanding of the plans
that will be uh put in place to tackle
the problems in town
it's not all about enforcement but
approving these provisions tonight
will certainly assist in these efforts
um
so chair i'm happy to take any questions
uh or comments from members
thank you thank you thank you donna uh
councillor golf
councillor hackett and then councillor
james in that order please
very much mr chairman um i'd like to
thank officer williams here for the
report as in front of us
it's a long time coming i know you've
persevered with this from here
officer williams and i give you my full
support so i'd like to
propose remove the recommendation set on
page 83 i've got it
is it the abc indeed um this to me is
very important for a bit of it itself
and it gives you the first step on the
ladder really for us trying to attack
against social behavior within time
center itself
um anything is going to give the
officers and police
a little bit more i say backup as such
to move things forward this would
hopefully set the president going
forward
that you know we respect our town areas
and villages
and the the behaviors in inside of these
villages and towns
uh the intoxicating substances is very
important to me
um unfortunately with the lockdown and
current situation we've faced
a lot of people turn to recreational
habits to
i suppose get away from the normality of
the
things we've gone through but to me this
is really really good i'm so pleased to
see it and i really do hope
that this will help biddeford on the
leveling up fund
it gives us chance you know we're trying
to start from the bottom to clean
ourselves up a little bit here
so i think we deserve every opportunity
for this level enough fun and this will
help us go through
so thank you much thank you
i'd like to say thank you very much for
that counselor
please yes sir thank you very much chair
um
i too would like to thank janet for the
work she's done
uh she's worked very closely with me
over this
and also i've been working with the
police officer
um who has previously retired now
but um officer the thought i would like
to
bring forward her comments
the current pspo has limited value
due to the small area that it covers so
we have before us
something is strongly supported by the
public
by the police it's merited and
importantly it's proportionate
and i don't know if you're taking the
second thing from councillor jones as he
intervened or you'd like to take my
seconding
of this motion which is very very
necessary
for the well-being of biddeford thank
you chair
thank you uh councillor james
yeah i don't think i need to add much
other than to um
thank you for the work i've obviously
been on the fringes of the
this um it does give us uh the control
we need
i think the current um order is either
running out or has run out
so this is an opportunity to get one in
place
which is slightly more substantial with
the the types of stuff it deals with
and the area it covers so it's a piece
of good work
and good work done to torridge thank you
thank you
uh council mackenzie and councillor
christie and then councillor inch please
um the question for janet um how long
does this pspo stand
um how long does it run for
it'll run for uh three years council
mackenzie the legislation requires that
there has to be
a review after after three years of any
um pspo
that was excellent because i was just
going to say that brunswick wolf would
be finished by then and
it would be nice to extend the scheme
over to that area because it's obviously
going to be a
a meeting point for lots of people and
everything was around the fines and the
um
sort of thing is there no um other way
that we could
deal with that sort of thing because
half the people that are going to be
fine probably haven't got those fines is
there no way of helping them with some
sort of rehabilitation
or education um compulsory education or
something like that
council mackenzie the um uh the courts
can
cause alternative sanctions to fines and
but what uh
we would uh intend to do um i've
mentioned about um bringing back a
a response plan to a future meeting it's
not all about enforcement we are looking
at
um engagement and education as well
um so it's it's whatever tool works uh
council mackenzie but if the matter did
go to court
then it's it's out of um tdc's hands
uh what the court subsequently imposed
okay thanks amazing work
counselor christie yeah i'd just like to
say thank you to janet for all the work
you've put in on this
um and it is actually quite unusual for
counsellors to see so many responses
on a social question rather than say
planning objections or whatever
and i found the responses actually very
interesting
there are two issues identified there
firstly the implementation and i know
janet has talked
about this you know implementation a bit
later
but could i ask the officers um could
they go through these responses and pick
out some of the
fairly specific items that have been
raised
the one that caught my eye was at number
18
um where they talk about victoria park
and the the gateway out at park lane
where children run out into
the road now that is a bit that is a
torridge
controlled park and i think we need to
look at that fairly quickly
it has been raised with me by a member
of public only in the last few days
actually but there is quite a few
specific items in here and i wonder if
our
officers would go through and just pick
out the ones
that they think they might be able to do
something about because clearly
these are upsetting or worrying
members of the public
i'm happy to respond i'm happy to
respond chair um i'm more than happy to
do that councillor christie
um that that particular item wasn't uh
specifically related to the to the pspo
provisions
and but um i understand completely and
uh we'll certainly have a look through
those comments in detail
if there is anything we can action or
forward on to another authority
uh to uh to to bring to their attention
we will certainly do that
thank you council arranged
thank you chair yes i mean this has been
a long time coming and i
i welcome this report is a good report
and a good
you know response like christopher
country christie said we had a big
response from
the public um you know like i say this
has been a long time coming because
this is one of the things that i've been
a bit of a counselor now for
some time and this has been one of the
things that comes up
regularly on social media and all sorts
of places
you know about um anti-social behavior
and drinking in the streets and drinking
in
places that uh you know are not very
good
um i'm just wondering you know the
enforcement i can understand
uh we have to get to the bottom of it
enforcement isn't the only thing but
you know just to move people on and
that's what we've been doing
so far we move them on from land to
vision walk
they go to the park we move them on from
the park they go to the
london office and things like that you
know i just don't want to see us
going down that road and just moving
people on
um because that's not the way we need
somehow we need to
stamp out the problem help these people
stamp out the problem
and um i understand what uh janet is
saying
enforcement is not the only thing i
would like to see
more or more education uh
on on this problem in this town thank
you
well i'm gonna have the last word myself
i echo all the comments that people have
made
uh as a northward counsellor all of this
is in my award as long as
along with coachella christian customer
golf and um as it's been said it has
been a very long long time coming
and i thoroughly you know i'm delighted
that this has now
happened um but i will be looking for
results over the next
uh 12 months or more and i expect to see
some results from this
i want the officers to be proactive on
this rather than
reactive as they have been in the past
because clearly we
haven't had one of these orders in place
for some time certainly not an effective
one
so yes thank you janna i am also
delighted so
thank you very much so we just need to
accept this document i take it we don't
need to vote on it do we
okay you don't need to vote on it yeah
you had a proposal canceling golf and it
was seconded by councillor jones
okay thank you such a long time ago i've
forgotten that um
can we take it to the vote then please
kirsty
thank you chair councillor belton oh
yeah four
councillor brenton or councillor bright
paul councillor brown
councillor bushby
councillor christie oh councillor clarke
councillor haynes or councillor harding
or councillor hawkins for
councillor hicks or councillor hudson
or councillor hurley or
councillor hutchings or councillor inch
for councillor james or
councillor jones or councillor langford
for councillor laws or
councillor leather or councillor locke
or councillor mcgoff
four council mackenzie
four councillor manly
councillor newton four councillor rossi
four councillor watson
councillor watson four
thank you that's unanimous chair thank
you kirsty
okay now item 19 please let's not
not have too much debate on this because
the play strategy
along with the counselors allowances um
is being recommended for um a deferral
certainly until the next meeting because
there's clearly
quite a bit well quite a bit more
information that needs to be
in place before we can debate it
properly
um or certainly so i'm led to believe
anyway
so i would i would propose that that is
deferred until
at least until the next meeting
i'll second that answer uh chairman
okay tom i don't seem to have got my
screen up with the hands coming up
that's disappeared
okay um try clicking on participants
again
chair currently they're currently
issuing councillor mcgoff
yeah coachella golf
thank you mr chairman i thought you'd
cut me out there mr chairman
i wouldn't dare yeah yeah mr oh i'd just
like to add also i was going to second
that
we defer it but can we just add in the
provision for a disabled swing please in
victoria park ends
that polly field please i am trying the
artist i'm never going to give up on it
thank you i don't i don't know what's in
the the play strategy personally but
presumably
that will be covered in there um so
hopefully we can get it deferred you
know to a future meeting and then
that can be explored in more detail
councillor james yeah i was just going
to say
um i agree there i'm quite happy for
that what we must remember is what's
capital
and what is repair um and so
i think there seemed to be some
confusion at ons
about the fact that there is a
repair budget and we don't
know exactly how much we would need if
there was a specific
budget so i think we just defer it
and i will ask more information for the
next meeting
okay well it's been proposed and
seconded can we take that to the vote
kirsty please
chair yes you can agree to fair you're
the chair
sorry i'm going to defer that but until
the next meeting now
um item 20 petitions to receive any
petitions
or any no chair thank god for that
uh 21 notices of motion um
uh 21a is a new written notice of motion
from councillor haines
um yeah this is rarely
about unfinished business this count
councillors
voted for a motion that jetski should be
banned from the slipway at churchfield
appledore
and to use bollards to achieve that aim
subsequently the motion was overturned
um on the basis that bollards
wouldn't really work and they'd upset um
sort of regular users of the estuary
which to my mind leaves still the
question of jet skis
and the problem which councillors
identified
um and since um this
the motion was overturned we've there
have been various discussions
and it's clear to me that councillors
the feeling of counsellors is that there
should be a further investigation of
options
to deal with jet skis um
i apologize for putting in a song of
quite a long meeting but the other
alternative of going to june
to my mind was delaying things because
as
time is going as time goes on and as
people in this country are coming out of
covid and taking holidays in this
country rather than going abroad
this means there's going to be more
pressure on churchfield slipway
and in my view the problem of jet skis
is going to get worse so i would like
a report done by officers please
um into all the possible options which
i don't think we we had previously
um to look at things like possibly
having a warden
looking at cctv um
engaging more with the police
looking at what other areas are doing
like in cornwall
dorset northern ireland wales
this problem is becoming familiar all
over the country
and or also of course along the coast
from here in kunmartin
and i think the report should also look
at what's happening in
government level i understand
legislation is possibly forthcoming
and also looking at things like um
trying to get
the s tree part of the marine protection
area where there would be greater powers
so i would propose officers produce this
report
um so that we can further consider
the jet ski problem take a chair thank
you
so coach christie yes i'd like to second
that and
uh i would um actually support what
council hayes has said about the time
element
um because i know councillor ford have
gone i think but
um he did raise this quite some time ago
and we are approaching the summer season
whereas councilman haynes has pointed
out we could have a lot of people
turning up
and uh we do really need to do something
about this because
if we have an accident this summer and
the public start looking at how long
it's taken us to get something done it
isn't going to look very good
thank you council another
thanks joe well i don't want to labour
the point but i can't support the notice
of motion because it talks about
preventing users of jet skis from
launching from the slipway i can't
support that because i don't believe
they should be stopped from launching
there
but i do agree that we really need a
proper
report done in due course and
i hear what's said about time being
short but there isn't there is time to
to look at it in the round uh the
monitoring of the car park
the fact that the bus has had problems
turning around on there
the camper vans which people have
complained about
parking where they shouldn't be it's not
just a slip way down there
it's more than that and i've said all
along we'll have an office
a warden down there dedicated to the
summer months
um to monitor this situation of the car
park and the slipway
and i'm pretty sure that the one or two
of these
the small minority of jet skiers who
seem to cause a problem
if there was somebody there all the time
through the day
monitoring what they're up to it'd
change but
but i can't support this notice of
motion when it talks about preventing
users of jet skis from launching in the
slipway
thank you council mckenzie and then
councillor newton
councillor mckenzie you're muted
oh thanks i was just gonna echo what uh
councillor leather said it's um
a daft idea just to prevent them from
using one particular launching spot you
know are you either for the the crafts
or against them in the estuary
it's unenforceable anyway but you know
we thrive on tourism and there's a lot
of
money being spent by these people um
yeah
monitor the car park so that the uh um
crafts are launched in a proper manner
and everything else but they've got a
designated area that they can use but if
you just prevent them from using this
slipway
they'll go to other sites you're not
solving a problem you're moving a
problem um you know
i know bank ending billy ford was um
muted as a
place to launch but that's not really
um a good idea because of the tides and
the state of the slip down there
and you just have jet skiers traveling
further to get to their destinations um
no i can't support this motion either
sorry can i just have a point of order
please mr chairman
yes council range well i thought
i thought that when the motion is
proposed and seconded
we don't have a debate here it goes
straight to a vote
and it seems like to me that we're
having actually this is going into a
debate which is you
you're quite not close you're quite
correct and it is ten past nine
so that is correct stacy if that is
sorry steve did you all come in there
okay that's that's the point i was going
to make notice
notice emotion and not for debate
thank you um okay it's been proposed and
seconded down
curse you we take it to the vote please
thank you chair
councillor belton good guest
councillor brenton four
councillor bright four
councillor brown gates councillor bushby
you're good councillor christie
councillor clark against
councillor craigie boar
councillor dart
against councillor gov
against councillor hackett against
councillor haines or councillor harding
against councillor hawkins
four councillor sorry
councillor hicks against
councillor hudson against councillor
hurley
against councillor hutchings against
councillor wrench against
councillor james again
councillor jones against
councillor langford four
councillor laws against
councillor leather
councillor lock okay castle mcgoff
abstain council mackenzie
against councillor manly
against
councillor newton against
councillor rossi against chancellor
watson
again
so that's seven four twenty three
against
and one abstention chair thank you
kirstie
that motion is lost counselor james
you've got your hand up
um just a question for the chair going
forward um do i take it that you will
not allow discussions
on um notices of motion because over the
last few years
we've discussed some and not others so i
just wanted you to confirm that they
will not be discussed in the future
they will be discussed in future if that
is the rule we will stick by the rules
thank you jeff yeah can i just say the
councillors seem to have gone against
what they voted last time it seems to be
rather inconsistent in my view thank you
thank you uh
okay item uh number 22
exclusions of the public do we have any
party items
okay we don't we don't so if we don't
have any party items we don't need to go
into part two so
that then is the end of the meeting i
take it
i i do i do beg everyone's pardon we're
taking so long but it was rather a long
agenda
as it was the agm i promise i will do
better